a little behind the scenes for you here
you go that's how you make a thumbnail
[Music]
Bohemian Rhapsody
so Bohemian Rhapsody is the biopic for
the lead singer of Queen Freddie Mercury
if anything about Queen for many years I
was not a fan of Queen just their music
it didn't click with me I just didn't
get it but as people do evolve their
tastes evolve my palate for music
expanded funny enough I feel like my
appreciation for Queen started going up
when my love for classical music also
started going up it's like they're in
sync with each other now I enjoy Queen
music cuz it's revolutionary is very
unique you can hear a queen song and you
know it's a queen song and whether
you're a fan of Queen or not we can all
agree dude was an interesting guy had an
interesting life and hands down the best
part about this movie rami malek
as Freddie Mercury this dude crushes it
he was great in here and it's so easy to
sniff out someone who's doing an
impersonation just like it comes across
as a really hollow impersonation of
somebody this is not the case here rami
malek became another human being
Oscar nomination in the works probably
if not I imagine there might be riots
dude he's just very charismatic there's
something about Rami Malek you know that
because I remember him from an episode
of 24 he might have been in a couple
episodes of 24 Onias he got blown up I
don't remember much of what happened in
that season but I always remembered him
even when mr. robot came out I was like
oh it's dude from 24 that one season in
that one episode of that one season
there's something about him II just
remember the guy so I think it was great
casting to play Freddie Mercury
obviously proof is in the pudding he was
I really this movie gripped me grabbed
me it interested me biopics are just a
difficult shanwa they're a difficult
type of movie to do I mean you're
telling a movie about someone who is a
human being who had a life who did a
career of some sort usually is the case
with a biopic so at that point it's like
what angle do you want to come at this
thing with I mean you have their
personal life their public life their
private life their professional life
what elements of that professional life
do you want to show you want to show the
business element of producers talking to
them you want to show the creative
process of the band making music you
want to show them on tour and what
that's all about this movie concentrates
on Freddie Mercury his personal life his
interactions with his bandmates is some
of the creative process I do wish they
showed more of the creative process you
get a couple of glimpses behind the
curtain of how a couple of songs came to
be I hope it's the truth of how it
happened because it was interesting but
there's just one scene where there's
just taken inanimate objects and they're
mixing them with instruments to make new
sounds I could have gone for that scene
being twice as long as it was
this is interesting to me but really at
that point it's like what element of
Freddie Mercury's life do you want to
see in this movie are you hoping to see
in this movie you might not see what you
wanted to see I've heard some people
talk about they wanted a deeper dive
into his personal life I mean you get
glimpses of that really secretive
personal life he had you're not really
gonna get more than a couple glimpses of
him walking off with a couple dudes
maybe after a huge party he throws at
his house but I'm more like the fact
that it addresses that thing that's just
baffling for a lot of people which is
like you have all this money you're
super famous how can you feel alone but
hey big lives big voids so really
importantly this movie was interesting
engaging it kept good pace movie was
over two hours long it didn't feel like
it dragged on it felt like it was in
good time can't say that about all
biopics but most importantly it
humanized a legend it's so easy to deify
these artists when we were young we see
actors we see musicians directors and
they're these otherworldly beings just
like their gods I like it when a biopic
can just humanize that and said no that
they're not beyond reach when you first
see him in this movie he's working at an
airport he's throwing baggage onto
airplanes so the next time you're at an
airport you see someone do that you just
go that could be the next Freddy Mercury
it just makes it really accessible I
love that and as it's easy to look back
and remember the best version of this
person this person made mistakes along
the way
as people do is we've all done and we
will all continue to do I don't like it
when biopic sir - squeaky clean it's
like don't change history show us the
grit show us the tumbles and Falls I
like this movie did that in the anti
Douglass movie this was a legit good
peek behind the curtain of the life of a
very influential artist not everything
smoothly gets all of its time to shine
sure whether you're a longtime queen fan
new queen fan or really not a queen fan
at all it's still worth watching because
it's an interesting life and if for
nothing else watch it just to appreciate
Rami Malik's performance he's pretty
[ __ ] good in there for me I will say
Bohemian Rhapsody is worth watching and
worth buying on blu-ray
alright so Bohemian Rhapsody have you
seen it what'd you think about it or
what's your favorite biopic out there
musical by out there I've probably asked
that 78 times but if your minds changed
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
any more
[Music]